YAT EWE
CK THIRVBI
CNN.S RY WILL BE CLOSED
GWAI THINK DLY THAT
APEVTHE  SCHOOLS IE COMPLITED B
TH B
SOYOTHME AS INAR
AD
OUBESTUSWE
>>G THE LARGT SURG
AD THE
JUST ASKHENG ECO.
ADULTS WHO TOR RUS WERE ABOEV
AT RSEEGATIVE.
FO
E TEMPARCLOSIN
BARS AND RESTAURANTS DESTE
N F EPG THEM OPE
HERE I RESPONDED T W G FROM THE
CORONAVIS SA C
THHO S
>> WHAT CR HE KE
SOMEIN
OF THE CHD E HEELIN WAYS OF ST.
HIWE
BUSINESS OWNERS, FOLLOW,WHO SCR,
THEA SACRIFICE WE
TO LET S>> HE WO
MONERK
PERSHOCOME PICK UP
THRB
>> PERHAPS THERE IS COMMON
AOC SINCE THAT IS THE CRF ARGUM
EBNAVIRUS
G THEI
LIVELIHOODS.
KIDS ARE OUT OF SCHOOLEY ARE
WHY ARE HO AND AURANTS ENRY. Y
CAPREXPEOULD THEOV THEM
AFLOAT IF THEYANBLICANS
PAINT ANY RESTRIN GOVERNMENT'S
FOUNDATION IS UG
GHATING NEARLY $
VACCINES TO POOR.
GATE HLSO DONATED BI
BUT DON'T TELL THAT TONET
NEOROMPUTER EXPERTF
TO TALK ABOUT COVID INSTEAD OF A
PHYSICIAN?
ABUT                    .O THAT.
COVID-19.ME ON
AND THA RH CONGM
CELEBRITY DOCTORF INTERNAL
MEDICINE, T E CONF
REQUESEMIOLO
TRUE HE ISN'T E GEEK ER WTOP,  R
BEDSIDE.
SECOND WAVE, IE
MONITORING AUSTRALIA.
N' ABIG  ASSIBLE THAT YOU WILL .
>> EVERYN, WOMAN,
CAMERA TV, THESAY THAT IS
>> I SPENT ATHE
THAT IS NOT E EXAMPL IT WAS IN
SODYVERY COGNITIVELY
ADVANCED.
>> NOW, THOCS
WE ON THE
CONDITIONS OF OTRSESPITE HOWN A.
IS NOT
A PHYSN, IST PONTIFICAN TH
PREST'
SHE HASN'T SEET.O ENIDEN'S CHART
OWNED Z                  A ADMI.
>> I HAVEN'T EXAMINED THE FORMER
VICE PRENT
SILT STROKES USE HE 30 FROM CAN
YEARS AGO.
.
THEY ARE PT EV
THEORIES.T
TESTING BEFOR
AND I'M THKIHY WE BENG
WELLT EL
AHAT
SHOWS THAT FO HAHI, YOU KNOW WH?
YOU KNOW WHAHELPS?
ED A ADD
>>OW HE BOTHERED ABOULL GATAN
PANDEMICS.
GOODS TO
IN HELE THARS CLEANEE BILL GATER
FIVE
O.ODSK OAL
INSTS LIKE 1
TH CAKELY T
INFECTIOUS VIRUS ER
N PANDEMICS, LET'SE EXPERTS THOT
T THROUGH
PT ABOUT NEW
BUT I WAS LIKE WHY AREN'T EY
TALKING ABTHBEUSNUMBER I
NOG.E IN
, AVYO
OIIMMUNITYWNS AND MASK MANDATESG
TELY
SPREADIN THING
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE. THETE
VE PEOPLE
A YEAR DYING F
NTS, 480,000 FRO360,000 A YEAR
SWBU DON'T
RY>> TANOUT OF THE CONTROL ATH
PRTEHE WORST SINCE
S WAY
MANY, THE SITUATION IS
BETTER, NOT WORSE.
CAN TAKE YOUR MASK  RIGHT
ABOUTCAN DAMAGE YOUEL
WEARING A MASK BECAUSE THEN
PO -OU BREATHING BACK, YOUW,
UNNY WE NOW KNOW THANKS TO BLOO
THATDL THEHIYORK WAS YOUD VERY
UARTERS THAT ARE
HANDLE
DOORKNOBS.
>> SPEAKING OFOO LY WHA AISARE T